hey Martin I've got something to show
you today take a look
this looks like an IDE with the cloud
run Hello World app uh Brian I think
we've seen this on serverless
Expeditions many times before
ah probably but have you seen it in an
IDE running in a browser tab backed by
the cloud
please
[Music]
whoa Brian how did you do that well it's
a it's a web-based IDE hosted by Cloud
workstations which is an on-demand
development environment with a dedicated
VM and container for each developer it's
based on cloud shell the console at the
bottom of our web thing if you've seen
that before Ah that's cool now how do I
create one of these myself well let's do
it right now
okay so if we go over here this one is
configured for General Google Cloud
development using Code oss the open
source base for visual studio code so
it'll work really well for serverless
work and that development environment I
mentioned these are defined using
container images so each workstation
pulls the image runs that on the VM for
the developer and we proxy connections
SSH TCP connections we proxy them both
over https with Authentication
and now we're back to that hello world
app
the home directory for you as a
developer is saved between sessions so
you can customize things and start and
stop the workstation as needed
very nice so it looks like you created
the workstation here from a template uh
now who makes those templates yeah so
that's going to be an administrator or
maybe you know somebody on your team
technically things like that and here it
is this is where we configure a template
for those workstations primarily that's
what container image to use and what
kind of VM to run it on along with
security settings there's also a cluster
which I've already configured here and
you need one of those per project and
you can share it across all these
configurations the templates and use it
for multiple workstations it takes a
little longer to start so I won't show
it right now all right and you said
development what kind of development
would you use these workstations for so
they are on-demand environments
accessible from anywhere that you have
web access from any machine with a
browser and you can customize what's on
them so you can use it for almost
anything these uh base images are Docker
images that gives you a consistent
environment across teams or within a
team and and I think really helps with
both that kind of like works on my
machine problem but didn't work
somewhere else and for faster onboarding
um and because it's a container image
you can customize it we have templates
with support for multiple IDs such as vs
code the code OSS version IntelliJ and
their various Ides like pycharm writer
and more and like I said it's container
Rich so you can customize it add new
extensions libraries ID plugins things
like that right right so that all sounds
useful but I think it sounds really
useful about this thing where the
permissions you have the permissions in
the cloud rather than on my local
machine because when I test on my local
laptop right here some things don't
translate well to the cloud like I am
permissions oh yeah I think that's what
I'm most excited about personally I've
coded over SSH you know in a terminal
for years because I don't think you can
really ever create the exact same
environment so this helps with things
like you you mentioned the permissions
being different or networking behaving
differently or things like that and I
think it will save a lot of time in
troubleshooting you might have had
otherwise and now that Ides can run in a
split mode where you have like remote
code and local GUI I think it's the best
of both worlds and workstation makes it
really easy to configure that for usage
on a whole team and okay so team you
said what kind of teams or developers
are these workstations meant for
personally I think it's most useful for
at least medium-sized teams and you know
maybe large organizations will be most
excited about it you know it really
gives you that standardized Dev
environment if you've got security
things you need to be consistent across
you've got certain things you want to
set up for everybody it's really useful
there anytime you've got to onboard new
developers quickly or or switch projects
a lot it's very useful yeah at my last
developer job at a startup it took me
the better part of a week to get my
machine set up with all the tools and
permissions so I want to try this out
could you guide me Brian absolutely I'm
a docs person so I would recommend
checking out the docs first because
there's a few Concepts that are worth
kind of getting settled it's pretty
small set of stuff and then give it a
try excellent thanks for showing us this
Brian totally and thank you for having
me you know check out the docs get a try
on your applications and this the whole
point of this is that it's customizable
so give it a go please very good I will
include that link in to the docs in the
video description and thank you everyone
for watching if you have questions for
Brian about these workstations please
add them in the comments also let me
know if there are other serverless
topics you'd like to see in future
episodes we read every single comment
until next time
[Music]
foreign